mach doch dein eigenes ding du [ __ ] was
willst du für eine gleiche
ich habe ja bereits mit einem video vor
einigen tagen in lagern da bedeutet auch
ein 4 hochladen möchte der youtuber in
der einfach darauf reagiert und ich will
auch in diesem video heute gar nicht
doch kleine dumme aussagen reagieren
würden euch einfach nur einige
kommentare zeigen die unter mein video
geschrieben wurden was müsste sich da
ein oder du geil auf die kleckse
dreckige arsch [ __ ] hundezone
laut der aussage von heroin bin ich ein
gerätehaus gepflegter hundezone
meine eltern er hat außerdem geschrieben
weil du geil auf die click geil bild
jedoch vielleicht erst mal in die schule
bei später von heute vor allem geil auf
klick das video weniger auf rufweite
durchschnittlichen video aufruf treffer
macht ansage gegen mcdonald's dass er
nicht durch die tür mac drei kommen kann
schauen wir uns nochmal so die tür tritt
an hat von kleiner junge durch das heißt
sowohl ich als auch bei der oper müssten
so breit sein die vier kinder
leute
vier kinder
nebeneinander live kamerabild wie kann
so einer zwei meter abo haben rede mal
richtig was du machst auf kleines kind
damit jeder mycroft ideen direkt kanal
abonnieren abschaum ballistik auf euch
mal nicht vergessen mit seiner letzten
aussage an ich fick auf euch man wie
kann man auf jemanden schicken
du kannst auch jemanden schicken also
wenn du auf ihm liegt da kannst du auf
ihn jemand anderen wir alle nicht
schreiben oder euch vernünftig
artikulieren lieber userin oder user mit
dem namen
wo der oder die jüngeren schreibt mir
diesen kommentar rede mal richtig mann
und dann schreibt
damit jeder minecraft knie
jeder mai kräftig
minecraft die hierzu gemeint dass ich
mal richtig reden will ich sagen gewährt
man eine autarke stück für stück durch
und schauen wo du dich vielleicht
verbessern könnte wie wird groß
geschrieben hat ein dass anfang ist kann
so eine wm ok ich kreis ist jetzt auch
mal ein weil er müsste eigentlich die
abkürzung für mädchen zeigen geschrieben
wird millionen wird abgekürzt auch ein
fehler aber ich habe nerven uns nicht
zwei millionen abos um zwei millionen
abonnenten abos sind die stripshow
selber getätigt habe ich glaub ich nur
30 stück und außerdem jetzt groß
geschrieben also nochmals zwei fehler
wir haben allein im ersten satz von
einem kompletten kommentar schon vier
fehler gefunden
ich bin froh dass zu wenig noch ein
fragezeichen dahinter gesetzt weil sonst
wäre das wieder der weiteren fehler
gewesen auf dem letzten kommentare bay
komm ich glaube ich mich dafür
rechtfertigen dass niedrige treten kann
wenn du nicht mal richtig wieder zu
stabilen kann wir machen einfach weiter
mit dem nächsten kommentar halali macht
es ohne beleidigung und du machst mit
mehr passt
da
ist denn bitte mehr bloody hat so wie
bei eigentlich so gut wie jeder andere
youtuber auch in deutschland ebenfalls
ein video so halb gegenwert gemacht hat
verfügt jeder hat eigentlich ein video
gegen seine auflagen gemacht und du
machst es mit mehr platz vielleicht habt
ihr das video hat noch nicht gesehen
allerdings wollte ich überhaupt nicht
gegen hetze ich habe ihn nie als person
angegriffen habe lediglich seine
getätigten aussagen angegriffen weil die
einfach schlichtweg total dumm und
hinter geblieben und so was von von von
40 milliarden jahren sind ich war allein
die tatsache dass er hassrede mit seiner
eigenen meinung argumentiert also das
ist logisch für dich von dieser
kommentar ist nicht wirklich böse
gemeint aber ich hatte mir nicht ich
kenne ihn nicht ich hatte seine aussagen
ich hoffe dass mir klar geworden er sagt
schlecht über leute zuletzt 1 lästert
aber über mehr oder was wert besser man
bruder gangsta rapper drake schlecht
über leute zu lästern lästert aber über
mehr oder was westermann bruder wie
bereits gerade schon gesagt ich habe
nicht immer wird gelästert mache ich war
gerade vielleicht leicht andeuten geben
dabei vielmehr um deine meinung und
jetzt lieber am kamin oder lieber mehr
falls dieses video sehen die bringen
jetzt bei was eine meinung es uns war
mehr bester mann
das ist eine meinung ich hoffe dass
auch gelernt und jetzt arbeite community
luft oder wie auch immer ich weiß ja
dass ihr zu mit einer tabelle hat weil
ich habe gemerkt dass sehr viele
kommentare auf die klassischen
eingegangen bin und ich werde noch auf
welche weitere eingehen haben
tatsächlich immer leid bekommen also
nicht so viele aber zumindest ein paar
like das heißt es die hand an die
wirklich alles durchgehen video die
gegenwert gemacht werden und da halt
einfach helfen mit wege haltet einfach
dagegen leicht positive kommentare in
den kommentaren also was wir gegen
homophobie oder lassen oder irgendwie
was ich selber bin nicht schwul aber ich
bin überhaupt nicht gegen schwule so es
sind normale menschen drei vor meinen
kumpels sind schwul leicht einfach
dagegen bleibt das video ich merke schon
wieder das was da für viele dumme kinder
hier ankommen werden und hätten ferner
halt doch kein bauland wenn du jetzt
deine meinung wer hat danach gefragt
alle wird gibt den anderen hoch macht
doch dein eigenes ding die note was
würde viele gleiche vermutet wiegand
gekriegt 34 wenn richtig zu
buchstabieren redenschreiben junge halt
doch kein maul abend geht aber wieso
soll ich keinen maul halten wenn schon
soll ich doch beibehalten wenn jupp
deine meinung wer hat danach gefragt
allenfalls die fragezeichen zu setzen
weiß ich über ein alter schreibt weiß
nicht was sie zwischen wellen und wenig
was siehst du nicht an anderen hoch mach
dein eigenes ding durch
würde ich mich anderen hoch auch wenn
sich immer dann anderen leuten ruft ihn
leute welche trotzdem dein eigenes ding
macht überhaupt keinen sinn band was
bist du für eine gleiche fame geile
huber ich weiß nicht wie man eine
gleiche film keine hose sind aber eher
ich empfehle dir mal ein altes interview
von mehr kinder sich aber anzuschauen wo
er selber gesagt hat auch wer weil ich
werde dieses schwulen wenn man niemals
akzeptieren könnte mich auch beleidigend
brauchen hat dieses video wenigstens
merklich zweifelten immer ein bisschen
diskutieren denn mich doch weil die
fäden der [ __ ] auch wenn er schwule
hacker und gibt ja seine meinung
nein
das ist nicht seine meinung dafür hat
rede
strafbar das ist deine mutter deine
mutter hat keine kondome ein like gleich
einmal sich weniger wird gleich dass
meine mutter grün ist egal
[Applaus]
ich weiß ja nie was ich dazu sagen soll
ich sagen ich habe jetzt ein profilbild
gewinnen das war die süße kleine
dann habe ich einen namen gesehen und
das war halt flying fact dann dachte ich
halt ersten fakten oder zumindest
werbung oder irgendwie sowas oder kommt
noch ein bullshit
mai gleich einmal mich weniger vergibt
mich irgendwann minuten10 mal oder wird
nur für klicks würden nicht durch einen
punkt alter
leute wir gehen dass man nochmal nach
rechtschreibfehler durch nur wirklich
den meistercup anfangen klick wird groß
geschrieben auf der zweite fehler der
dritte fehler etwas mit k geschrieben
mit in deutschland platz dahinter
vergessen einen punkt oder ein
ausrufezeichen verletzt das heißt es ist
schon der vierte rechtschreibung
grammatik fehler ist einfach komplett
falsch normalerweise müsste ich jeder
für einen treffer für jeden groß
geschrieben wird weil erweiterten das
anfangs zwei buchstaben verletzt aber
ich gebe mal nur ein dach findet bei
fünf fehlern in den ersten vier fertig
sein
zum punkt gesetzt die fragezeichen das
heißt weg fehler
verkehr
sechs fehler
wenn jemand von euch eventuell deutsch
hilfe gibt ich habe hier sehr viele
kunden damit keine frage von crafter
strich lukas joppich eigentlich was wert
macht über dich mal um deine sache und
nicht über die der andere wieder
komplett hat zwar auch eine menge fehler
drin allerdings will ich gar nicht ob
die fehler eingehen sondern wirklich mal
ein kleines statement abgeben hier
reiche eine youtuber wird die zahl der
youtube community und mehr hat mit
seinem video große teile der youtube
community angegriffen weil er gesagt hat
dass alle schwule [ __ ] willen der
teilweise youtuber angegriffen
mittlerweile rap songs machen dass sie
es nicht können dass sie auch
[ __ ] wird und auch wenn er mich
direkt nicht angegriffen hat und auch
nicht indirekt weil ich nicht schwul bin
ich bin kein rapper ich mache eigentlich
gar nicht einig hat er mir wirklich
nichts getan war der trotzdem freunde
informiert was angefahren und einer
community und der kompletten youtube
community
und natürlich versuche ich die youtube
community zu schöpfen dadurch dass ich
meine eigene audienz darüber informierte
dass seine aussagen schlichtweg falsch
sind und ich finde ich habe überhaupt
nichts verwerfliches getan war klar dass
du tun will sich dazu äußert zu
kartoffel lutscher möchtegern
deutschland
ich bin möchtegern deutscher also
ich bin deutscher
ist eine beleidigung deutscher zu sein
die kartoffel lutscher jetzt wünsche ich
auch noch kartoffeln er dem hack hahn
dessen frisches profilbild manama
lucia
und deutschland ja anscheinend zuschauer
von mert bist hätte schon gedacht dass
seine beleidigungen ein bisschen
kreativer sind kommen wir jetzt zu einem
kommentar wo ich wirklich gedacht habe
okay der ist wirklich einer der
krassesten kommentare der trift nicht so
von allen kommentaren der arcadia man
arbeiten ich habe mir wirklich geholfen
als ich diesen kommentar wirklich mir
vor augen geführt habe
[ __ ]
unten
wo brutal draufsteht [ __ ]
ist eine beleidigung du sagst damit
quasi dass ich weder liebe und das ist
eigentlich auch keine beleidigung also
ich meine leute männer es gibt leute die
damit gehört die frauen lieben es gibt
leute die bei betrieben also hey ich
liebe frauen aber
ich sehe jetzt schon kommen die ganzen
leute auf dich ist der eingang wird ich
bin ich jetzt schon wieder die
kommentare in den kommentaren kiefernweg
nächste wahl kommt aber nicht richtig
gut und wirklich gefordert und die
kommentare dann jetzt runter kommt
wahrscheinlich auch wieder mit noch mehr
rechtschreibfehlern pendant für smart
last mehr wert sein auf dem sarg der
diese albert sagen ihren videos nicht
einmal hsv aber kommen mir darin video
damit an und nicht nur rapper der mit
einmal im check wahlzettel solchen sagte
ayala setola auf den computer habe ich
nicht verstanden
ich weiß nicht was du damit bewirken
wollte tuner mit dem namen mr
aber was auch immer nur mittel gegen
wollte glaube ich nicht so ganz geklappt
also
wenn die mit wasser damit meint dann
schreibt gerne die kommentare aber ich
weiß nicht was er damit meint ihr habt
keine ahnung genutzten einen tropfen
blut auch der imam
mein kopf wieder auf wie sie kenne ich
habe keine ahnung was die klemmen
bedeutet weil ich kein türkisch leider
kann ich find die sprache unglaublich
interessant also ich würde ich gern mal
lernen aber ich habe eben kurz weil
google nach was die tat bedeutet
mein kopf sieht aus wie ich häufig
das heißt wir aus wie ich häufig
auswählen hey leute ich sie aus wie ich
aussehe
das hat sich mit dem die gemeinde damen
und herren ich hoffe ich konnte euch
irgendwie unterhalten viele sachen hier
forschen tirol ist und spaß zu verstehen
allerdings auch wirklich besser viele
sachen also diese leute der ami haben
den kompletten bullshit in die
kommentare geschrieben also wenn
immobilien das jetzt wieder tun sollten
und wieder irgendwelche schwulen oder
was letztlich beleidigen leuten dann
hätte dagegen nicht leicht diese
kommentare frau positive kommentare
verbreitet liebe ich liebe euch keine
ahnung leicht bitte dieses video einfach
weil das der weg wieder das vielleicht
haben wir verlegen solchen leuten die
hassrede als persönliche meinung an wen
ihr findet sie und weitergebildet da
könnte ich meinen kanal korbwurf
abonnieren kraft keine videos mehr
finanzieren andere video eingeblendeten
hier oben meinen shop in dem es am 20
dritten 1000 signiertes ticker gibt
und neuer rudi wird gelaunt